[both grunting]
- WOULD YOU JUST
SHOVE IT IN?
- OH, OKAY,
SHOVE IT IN, DEBBIE.
WHO DOES THAT?
THIS IS HOW I ALWAYS DO IT.
I FIDDLE AROUND WITH IT
UNTIL IT FINDS ITS OWN WAY IN.
IT'S VERY NATURAL.
- OH, MY GOD,
HAS THAT EVER WORKED?
I CAN'T EVEN TELL
IF YOU'RE IN YET.
HERE, JUST LET ME GRAB IT.
- UGH, YOU'RE STARTING TO
SOUND LIKE YOUR MOTHER.
LET ME TAKE CARE OF THIS.
- HONEY, I CAN ALWAYS JUST GET
A NEW ONE TO PUT IN THERE.
- HELL, NO!
NO, I CAN DO THIS.
UGH, COME ON.
COME ON.
YES!
IT'S IN.
YOU READY TO SCREW?
- FINE.
LET'S JUST GET THIS OVER WITH.
[both grunting]
- THERE!
LIGHT BULB IS NOW SCREWED IN.
TA-DA!
BIG REVEAL.
- TOOK LONG ENOUGH.
I COULD'VE FINISHED IT
FASTER MYSELF.
- NEXT TIME WHEN I'M LAZY
AND JUST WANT TO WATCH CARTOONS,
I'LL LEAVE IT UP TO YOU.
WELL, THAT'S ENOUGH SCREWING
FOR ONE NIGHT.
- OH, MAN!
I WAS REALLY HOPIN'
TO JERK OFF TO THAT.
- FINISHED!
[gulping]
U.S.A.!